la première ministre elisabeth bornes
qui a remis ce matin sa démission
emmanuel macron le chef de l'état qui a
refusé c'est une erreur il fallait
accepter cette démission on est comme on
l'a dit est donc quelque chose de très
mouvant de très instable et probablement
d'intenable et dans ce cadre là à part
une nouvelle dissolution on voit pas
très bien l'issue madame borne me semble
être très mal cap est pour aujourd'hui
rédaction du gouvernement parce qu'il me
semblait très faible dans sa capitale
est très inaudible bon on a l'impression
si vous êtes depuis sa nomination
qu'elle est tombée dans un trou qu'on
l'a plus jamais entendu refuse la
démission de madame ben parce qu'il n'a
personne à nommer elle est là la vérité
est que l'intégralité des personnes à
qui il a proposé le poste de premier
ministre ont toutes refusé isabelle
borne quelqu'un d'autre j'ai pas sûr que
ça changerait grand chose en réalité sur
les projets qui sont ceux d'emmanuel
maintenant c'est plus les résultats des
législatives qui devraient faire des
pressions deuxième information c'est
emmanuel macron va chercher avec les
chefs de parti des solutions
constructives
envisageable dès pas question de trahir
ceux qui nous ont fait confiance et ceux
qui nous ont élus nous ont pas élus pour
entrer dans quelques pâtes ou coalitions
que ce soit une j'en ai lu sur les
projets qui étaient les nôtres donc la
période jupitérienne elle est terminée
et c'est les français qui l'ont dit
c'est pas c'est pas moi qui le dis et je
pense que il faut que le président en
prennent conscience et qu'il accepte
d'entrer dans une autre phase qui est
une phase beaucoup plus parlementaire en
marche dit à l'assemblée nationale ça va
être desquels des canard sans tête
et si je voulais osé la comparaison les
autres groupes d'opposition ce sont des
têtes brûlées ils ont intérêt à y z'ont
intérêt à ce que le système tombe à
peine arrivé à l'assemblée rachel kéké
impose son style et sa personnalité
aujourd'hui c'est sur l'ancienne femme
de chambre et le dimanche dans le val de
marne tous les appareils photo sont
tournés les insoumis ont décidé de
déposer une motion de censure contre la
première ministre elisabeth baume pour
la faire démissionner mais vous n'avez
pas été consultés c'est ça non bien
russell dit vraiment on voit bien qu'on
a atteint les limites de danse que nous
sommes aimés est la faucille ont par
exemple du groupe communiste dit autre
chose en fait ivy isolé au sein du ps en
ce que ce que ce que je veux dire
simplement est ce que vous vous allez
vous associer à cette motion de censure
bon souhaite déposer d'abord nous avons
un groupe et comme on le fait à chaud
vous avez un groupe oui nous allons
avoir un peuple à l'assemblée nationale
les députés de la france insoumise sont
arrivés tous ensemble pour la
traditionnelle photo de famille 84 avec
jean luc mélenchon qui n'est plus député
un groupe aurait pu pourrait permettre
[Musique]
ce mélenchon a voulu tordre le bras de
ses alliés socialistes communistes et
verts en les étouffant au sein d'un
groupe qu'il aurait dominé que l'un
d'eux que lé fille aurait dominé et bien
ses alliés ont dit non mais nous on
reprend nos billes il faut quatre
groupes ça permet d'avoir beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus d'initiatives de
voix au chapitre de commission denquête
de prise de parole et donc ça peut
paraître contre intuitif mais c'est en
étant séparés qu'on est beaucoup plus
puissant il a toujours été dit est
annoncé je voulais dit d'ailleurs moi
même qu'en réalité il y aurait quatre
groupes c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous avais dit que nous pourrions avec
le premier groupe d'opposition nous
sommes le premier groupe d'opposition
comme une mer déchaînée dans un ciel
ombragé aussi impressionnante soit elle
cette photo prise dans le minnesota
n'est pas trafiqué ce ne sont pas deux
images mélanger mais bien des nuages aux
allures de bague